what does it feel like watching your may
walk out in front of five and a bit
thousand people yeah I think it is just
there's a very sort of clear vision
about you know how far we want to take
this where it's not completely mapped
out of how we're gonna do it but I think
Danny's willingness to try stuff and my
sort of relentless message in making it
happen that's kind of where it's been a
real success I think I did the o2
Academy at the year before unchurched
six months before that so it was like
all two academies the biggest venue in
Leeds where do we go looks as if there's
a video of me on my snapchat heading to
the or to going one day one day I'll
play here nan I'm joking but it's always
nice to dream right you imagine you're
in Newcastle city centre and one person
screams as loud as they can you hear
that person over to 3,000 people around
you imagine that times 5,000 all at the
same time for you as you stepped out and
I mean you're like oh my god how's this
even real
ladies and gentlemen welcome back it's
daddy T hi Danny how are you my tongue
good I'm good I'm good what flesh it's
been so long coming to get you on here
oh no we've just been speaking about 20
minutes before this though I don't give
me that's what you can't get straight
into it there's got to be a bit of
foreplay I mean that was the cunnilingus
how are you in a while but it's not just
you it's not if he's probably this is my
introduce summer I'm Casey the music
manager a friend he reels me and keeps
me from getting myself in trouble what's
it like being Danny's manager Casey and
fun alongside Challenger what's the
challenges you come up against and
mostly toning down his wild ideas have
you got any wild ideas that you've not
let through recently that you can say on
camera I believe a few Instagram stories
yeah I mean the post of view that semi
naked before your show was a that was a
bit of a battle between us as to where
that got censored right no it went up I
wouldn't know
okay yeah but though this is just sort
of a routine back and forth between
what's allowed and what's not
I understand but it's all part of the
fun craziness there is Danny's personal
brand I get it so Danny you're a DJ I
guess that's you play music right I do
press play on the deck once just press
in stung there and leave it leave it
deals a little bit but you've heard it's
like last few years you know for the
people that don't know about Danny's
kind of surge through popularity
especially recently that you just sold
out Leeds first director inna yeah yeah
floss London sold out how many was how
many people's up with five nine thousand
five and a half thousand people and
you're just I mean you're a very good DJ
but you're just some fella yeah I mean I
think that's one thing that makes it
more popular is the fact that I am just
some that would be everyone's pal like
it's not like oh my god I've got to go
the superstar it's like I know what his
dogs are called which is part of the
kind of how the followings come because
people just want it to be part of like
the life that I was living at the time
which is got more sensible over the
years but the parties have got bigger
and bigger on there so you know you're
probably a pretty good role model for
the local club DJ that is now taking it
to the absolute enth degree right yeah
if I really wanted to to push themselves
and go further yeah a lot say they want
to a lot don't really want to put in the
work they think it was easy think it was
they think what they've seen is the
route rather than why I've actually done
that they won't have ever seen
they just think like they can we can do
that that I mean we can go there now I'm
not saying we shouldn't try but the
beats jihad I'd love to see more people
doing it is there's a there's a massive
gap for where I was two three years ago
and just to sort of build on that I
think you know what people were sort of
seeing the past maybe year or so is the
combination of what I've worked with you
for years now they even prior to me
coming on board that was you know
there's things that you did beforehand
which I sort of come into the head now
and that's it's the combination of all
of those years yeah
I think the quote that I love that kind
of relates to what you were talking
about there is people grind away and
grind away and grind away and it takes
them ten years to become an overnight
success yeah yeah that's 100% true but
at the same time I get so many messages
like I what's the easiest way or what's
the quickest one what did you just get a
message a question for the podcast as we
started that hey man what do I need to
start DJ yeah you're like well some DJ
decks yeah there's part of me that
thinks that's I just been Floyd
Mayweather like what rap should I buy
but you have moved themselves through
this route right like ask them the
questions that matter
so I ladies and gentleman and put
fledgling DJs I am gonna strap
captain I'm going to ask all the
questions that everybody wants to know
so the first question I want to know
right I'm a I'm a young DJ maybe I've
got a couple of nights a week local gigs
maybe support slots a couple of warmups
maybe just about getting my first you
know main slot and okay see you tonight
in a typical town in the UK how do I get
myself from there to getting booked in
venues abroad to having a genuine
following on social media that care
about me to being able to release mixes
that people listen to like what do i do
where do I start
one thing people get really really mixed
up is social media and real world
social-media followings can look massive
and not be big in the real world whereas
some people can have quite small
social-media followings but bits be
touring the world as no nah it's like if
you look her
Craig David's got a massive social media
presence now but when he first came back
he had like 60,000 Instagram followers
and was selling out a weekly pool party
with 5,000 people in Ibiza like that
figure on Instagram is something that
people focus far too much on instead of
real live people like you imagined that
that desperately trying to get more and
more online followers to try and share
their music online so the value of that
compared to it might be different now
but when I first started handing someone
a CD that they would listen to and stay
in their car for five years even longer
there was a guy stopped me in the middle
of the street in Bristol that still had
my CD in his car from 2014 like that's
so much more valuable like investing in
yourself is so much more valuable than
focusing on a figure of Instagram
followers because I know people with a
third of a million followers their skin
man it's a perfect example of that I was
talking about the secret today and the
secret is this book film where people
it's like think it see it achieve it but
it removes the hard work from it it's
like yeah off your ass and actually do
thing you need to do and I think a lot
of the time people use that quantifiable
metric of popularity which is how many
followers do I have or whatever it how
many replies did I get yes bro if you
don't add 300 tickets when you get
booked by a promoter like myself it
doesn't matter I do not give a flying
[ __ ] about how many followers you you're
on Instagram I want to know if I booked
you for X many hundred or thousand
pounds how many more how many more
people are coming through the door if
that figure ends up being around about
like either zero or positive as in you
make me more money than you cost me I
will continue to book you because you're
the freest money I'm ever ever ever
gonna make and just to sort of build on
that I think is if you like essentially
social media or following is a it's a
number on a screen but particularly for
DJ's like first and foremost you are an
entertainer your sole purpose as to why
you exist is to entertain people
so therefore rather than questioning you
know if you're going to start up and try
and like build your brand or accumulate
followers look at how can I entertain
people how can I you know start getting
people to want to come and see me focus
on the things that matter rather than
you know build another metric that's
okay so not focus first and foremost is
that for a DJ tell me what's the steps
do different things in a club if you get
opportunities take them and make sure
people know it's that something has
changed something's different
something's different about that
platform if they're watching a resident
DJ and it's it's a resident DJ's job to
keep it like this all night rather than
smash it for five hours because the
crowd just wouldn't be able to hold it
but you get an opportunity to step on
even if it's the last hour if you make
that last hour increasing just anything
just like the intensity the music there
everything about the room just increases
people will want to know why is that
different and the more they're asking
why is that different than they see
somebody and they see their logo up on
the screen number like ah the last hour
its own circle but so good last night
was shown saw that we're playing they
can tell tell one person that one person
takes five of their friends to go they
go away till ten
people straightaway about 50 people that
know that you're different to what
they're used to
you're more exciting so they want to go
and see you more why are you more
exciting because I think you are but I
want you to define why you know I just
is it the turntablism is it the mixing
in atrocity it's a bit of like the speed
that I actually mix up the fact whether
I do it live or not the crowd don't care
the crowd care about what comes out of
the speakers but the the speed and the
flow of which I mix up means that
there's never a log that's just my style
there's never a point in my set where
the crowd actually get time to breathe
have you ever been sorry to interject
that have you ever been in clubs like a
proper resident yeah yeah I spell did
you how do you don't work because you've
just identified and you know sort of
people that are listening that maybe
don't understand music that much and
what I've been out clubbing anyone will
know when they've gone in in a DJs just
smashing the tits off it like whom house
tombs are getting played and you think
this feels a bit fast and you're like
yes it feels a bit faster to 136 beat me
yeah yeah yeah it Scott - Scott - built
about me how can you do that how do you
do that before we get back - why are you
different like how do you make Danny tea
a resident DJ in a club that plays a
four hour set just network you know as
party you know I was just going out all
the time what was the music like I
started off with house music but my
first proper residency was an hour and B
night because I just wanted to play
music I just really wanted to play music
and it got to about two hours before the
night was about to open which I even had
a cut of the night three or like me and
two friends got off at the Friday night
clubbing leads brand-new just opening
and and I would be four I was like oh
honey I ain't got any music so I'm there
like all I choose like buying Osher
albums and now look back it was the
complete wrong meetings a big forum for
the night that it was but that was a
stepping stone that was an opportunity
that I got that I grasped and tried my
hardest we the nuts that's what you
gotta do just take every opportunity
and they're in a rulebook there isn't a
rulebook either like what works for me
might not work for somebody else
so we've touched on different because of
the speed of mixing in and out why else
what else makes your sets different why
people sitting up and listening to you
you've seen about three hours recording
I've managed to get Danny not only here
and get a podcast out with him but then
strapped him to a set of decks they're
going to play it quids in you got some
later on tonight but you know I mean
like what what is it is it is it mic
work is it mic works got a lot to do
with it they asked gotta love you can
add so much personality with mic work
you can be you can almost make the crowd
want a challenge and better each other
which is like right I'm gonna go crazier
than that person without actually saying
can you go a bit crazier than them
please not each other's heads off yeah
without going too far you can really you
can control a crowd you can literally
like you can have the crowd in the palm
of your hands like you could literally
like I don't know it's hard it's hard
it's hard to describe because I just do
it I don't think about it now it's come
from it's never been like right let me
sit back and think how can I do this
it's always being a slow progression of
building up and yeah that works better
so I'll use that that works better so
I'll do that and it's it's been a slow
progression so to me it's not like a lot
think about it it just happens now so
thinking back is actually quite hard to
think how could I be like only babe I'm
asking you to unlearn everything yeah
right which is really all that again is
it it's gonna be a challenge yeah I want
to ask and this I want ask both of you
guys separately this the same question
right last long years playing gigs doing
all this sort of stuff and then hometown
leads you sellout leads first director
inna five and a bit thousand people like
what the first off Casey what does it
feel like watching your mate and client
whatever you want to call it walk out in
front of five and a bit thousand people
and it's weird we had a conversation at
the start of the year it was very much
like
okay obviously off the back of Leeds
Arena like where we move from here sort
of like what the alternative I did
because I did the o2 Academy the year
before
yes unchurched six months before that so
it was like well two academies the
biggest venue in Leeds where do we go
next
like knock at door as if there's a video
of me on my snapchat after I've got my
haircut heading to the or to going one
day one day going possibly zarina and I
was like actually said this I agree 165
days I literally went one day one day
one day I'll play here now and I'm
joking but it's always nice to dream and
that was just over a year before so he's
walking out what's it I think at that
time it was it was just an idea but I
think anything that we sort of set our
thought out to do it like it has
actually happened that way and that's
not true like you can sit here and say
or on the traction or it's this that and
the other but yeah I think it's just
there's a very sort of clear vision
about you know how far you want to take
this where it's not completely mapped
out of how we're gonna do it but I think
Danny's willingness to try stuff and my
sort of relentlessness it in making it
happen that's kind of where it's been a
real success and that he has very very
crazy ideas I can kind of tone them down
or refine them or shape them into
something that's gonna elevate what
we've already done and yes it's just
it's nice to see like Danny doing
something he loves
and obviously there's other benefits
that come from that but yeah I think to
put someone in an environment where they
get to do something that they love every
single day
you know earn a living off of it but
that's that's that you've been the
biggest reward of it that's awesome
Danny walked out on stage phonenumber
thousand people I it was just like
there's no way to describe it
right you imagine you're in Newcastle
city centre Litzy Center walking down
and one person screams as loud as they
can you hear that person over to 3,000
people around you imagine that times
5,000 all at the same time for you as
you stepped out and I mean you're like
oh my god how's this even like how's
this even
real house even afterwards for four or
five days afterwards I was still like
I'd watched the wall at the video of me
walk it out and I was like however how
have I even done that like how how is
that even a chiva below a possibility or
like he did just seem like just just not
even real not even real at all
that's cool man but like that's you do
your actualizing you get into what it is
they but my point was how I nervous I
want I want nervous at all I'd learn to
people messy garbage so nervous and I
was like Tim iPhone can't see people
telling me I should be nervous cuz I'm
not if I didn't want to do this I
wouldn't have tried to do it like I
wouldn't have sat there and gone I want
to do this why would I be nervous cuz
I've chosen to do it I'm not doing it to
impress all the people up do it because
it felt good and it was the next
progression for me and myself in my
career and I spoke to cosy I spoke to
Kristoff about this and he says that
even now he'll play for him a small-size
gig which might be enough two thousand
to five thousand people like the small
it takes he plays he still shits himself
every time this is a guy who supported
Eric Prydz
on New Year's Eve Eve Eve New Year's Eve
even New Year's Eve like for the last
few years played at the biggest venues
plate Creamfields played everything
first the first issue lineup released
for Creamfields this year and ultra has
him on the the top banner and he's like
drinking desperately trying to calm his
nerves but doing it like his ex missus
got him doing breathing exercises before
he goes but you know other this is the
difference he's come in from being sat a
computer making music progressing making
better music loving music making music
he loves to then having to be a DJ i've
come from being a big personality party
animal DJ then i've learned to make
music so the the ballsy side of it the
me being on stage is no problem because
i've been on stage thousands of times
before yeah I think it's not like I'm
chucked in at the deep end it's like
yeah I've gone I've gone through
like to me someone took me in a studio
with four people surrounding me that's
where I'm like even Eric Prydz with
something yeah oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my God where is he's the exact
opposite I think so to push back on that
a bit Christoph's played a lot of gigs
yeah back in the day he'll have played
thousands but this is something that I
know that we wanted to get onto which is
to do with mental health and other
things and I thought this in my mind for
ages it's unbelievable that there are
people out there who have a particular
talent in one area like a eccentrically
brilliant talent in one area of their
life but they don't have the personality
makeup which allows them to maximize it
and yeah easily the the perfect example
of this is Avicii you know you have this
guy who is capable of making the music
capable of playing the shows he does the
branding he does you know everything but
he doesn't have the personality which
allows him to deal with the lifestyle he
didn't want to do the shows though he
was pulling his shows he didn't want to
be doing the shows that was a he
couldn't handle that much attention
albeit like the social media side of it
as well would have been massive but like
it is crazy you could you could be in a
room with a thousand people if one
person says you [ __ ] that hurts
999 people could think you're amazing
and that feels great but that one person
that could literally just or even tweet
afterwards that's like a second kind of
a second wave of insults now someone
don't have to just say it to your face
they could tweet you afterwards while
few people probably will say to your
face yeah yeah yeah yeah well I know who
the Mike Tyson the right Tyson do you
see the Mike Tyson thing that's blown up
today what is it this social media has
allowed people to be brave enough to say
things say horrible things without
getting punched in without getting
punched in the face and that's so true
how about people of like slimed me off
online walk up to me like face-to-face
and shake my hand and then I've realized
afterwards
that being held at me although I was
like how do you have the balls to do
that online but that in real I feel like
just scared it's not exactly smallest I
mean what what have you been doing that
how we see people that don't know can
you tell us first off about what happens
every summer with regards to your
lifestyle and then can you tell me about
how you've coped with that what your
coping mechanisms are and whether there
were any periods where you were kind of
not doing the self-care and maybe the
room yeah yeah so I'll go back a bit
further first because if there's only
like resident DJ's that really want to
get themselves out there go into brands
one of the best things that you'll do go
to a season abroad good new five seasons
are probably just go and enjoy yourself
just like a table yeah just just go just
go and do it I I started to build a
following in malya by using what we've
discussed before that's where it all
trying to started before the online
stuff started it started in in real life
like I was a resident Casey came out
this is before I decide be my manager he
came out as a friend tamale it for four
days
I'm like why are you why are you still a
resident DJ and I was like to say so I
love it I get to play at these massive
clubs on the weekend it's brilliant it
was like there's 25 guys over there with
Danny tee tee shirts on that you don't
even sell they've had the mid themselves
and there's four guys over there just
got your name tattooed on them like way
still the resident you could definitely
get booked as an artist and that's how
it all started that is literally how
that is like - how about side of things
all right as abroad make a difference
why does this season everything's more
heightened abroad everyone's more
excited everyone's got to they hold on
to those memories they see someone seven
nights in a row on holiday they
associate that with having a great time
being drunk
meeting new people and if you've made
there ninety seven nights in a row
they'll love you forever there's people
coming tonight that saw me and Molly
here in 2012 13 14 like they'll remember
you forever
they literally like people people are
trying to book me for like can you talk
you can play in my wedding I'm marrying
a girl I met in Mallory 2014 people
remember like I would love absolutely
to see a Danny T wedding sir I did I did
really do Dominican with my friends my
friends why would I wait over to the
first track geez okay so go abroad and
then tell me like what's a week give me
a week Monday at Sunday what's a week
right so that was one of you still
actually gone just live over there for
like a hundred days all over now the
last two years have been about like
three or four week pleasing results it'd
be Friday and I in the UK geek somewhere
anywhere in the UK Saturday same again a
gig in the UK straight to the stretch of
the airport Sunday flights where results
on there playing that bizarre than the
monday two flights to get from one great
resort to another great resort last
summer i managed to get two days in
sunday where i was just working the
Monday and then Tuesday actually just
got to chill and then two flights to
Napa on the Wednesday fly back Thursday
have a day with my missus from Thursday
and then straight back to UK Friday
times 15 weeks so I like I saw eight
million till September yeah June June
until September I did like 87 flights I
think it was awesome and I was petrified
of flying like I was like I don't like
hey the word anxious and anxiety but
asked I was nauseous
sweaty palms oh my god really dive if we
turned right like I was the worst fly
what you like after 87 flights then I've
conquered my own fear through breathing
exercises because you've done the same
thing Chris I've done the same thing
you're through breathing exercises but
just through exposure therapy it's like
if your dream is to deejay around the
world and the thing that you have to
overcome to do that is flying it's a you
have something which allows you to
transcend your fear hey it Prince won't
fly pretty sweet does oh I'm very I mean
how do you think
get tobacco they doesn't swim yeah I got
to get trade no no he does he does fly
but I'm very limited and cause he said
this year so he doesn't fly across
America doing in America tour imagine if
you're doing East Coast to West Coast
like he's on he's on the bus with Kazi
here and like Christos just sat there
like a [ __ ] been there in three hours
yeah okay so you've spoken about how
about the flying but you know that's a
your sleeps being messed up you DYI
training and nutrition like how are you
what's your headspace like have you had
periods where that's really damaged you
or did you have periods where your
headspace one way would have been more
physically exhausted mentally exhausted
than actually like felt low like a lot
of DJ's a lot of DJ's will play a
massive massive gig play in front of
lots of people whether it's an artist
are a resident leave and then they feel
horrendous they feel really low upset
they don't like what's going on the like
they feel as if they've let everybody
down it's like and I get where that
would come from but I love that time
afterwards like after after the arena
show five and a thousand people left I
went another wonder and a smile just
wandered around the arena like as if all
these people came and stood here like
that to me I I loved that I I like a bit
of like private time whereas for a lot
of DJ's especially when like alcohol
amongst all the things are involved it's
like oh my god this is amazing the nice
building then a big draws are my friends
that's that's precisely what Christophe
broke on our podcast yeah yeah for him
especially because of how ruthless his
tour is he'll go three or four days
without being in a bed sometimes yeah
because of the the length of the flights
the change of the time zones the number
of flights and and transfers and stuff
and he said I wonder whether or not
Casey is this part of the saving grace
for this and the fact that you've
constructed a team that is around you
because cause he doesn't have a tour
manager hmm so he plays this gig he'll
smash it smash the ass off support in
fair play or bear or whatever it might
be and then come back to a hotel room on
your own surrounded by a bit of room
service
I'll stay with us David Casey Casey
doesn't tall with me Casey's like Casey
lives his life how I live my life and
when I'm not DJ like I'm in bed by 10
o'clock yeah but I think like so I'm
going on even sort of further to what
you said like the fact that you kind of
had your heyday and party day when you
was a resident yeah you've kind of lived
those experience now because you are so
motivated music playin with your career
etc there is for some DJ's that that
drive an urgency to have that escapism
you know we've let drinkin off the bear
sets to avoid that sober come down if
you like of oh this is the reality that
I'm faced with I've just gone from being
on stage and having this massive wire
and then you know sort of the
realization that comes after that where
some people will try and escape it with
the alcohol etc I think for you because
you can kind of embrace it any whether
you like it and you want to be motivated
the next day for work but that's where
you go for me the lowest of the low
feeling would be telling myself I'm
getting up at 11 o'clock and waking up
at 7:00 p.m. and thinking are what would
deflect myself down here that's that's
much worse for me like but if I'm on
stage for 60 minutes as much as I'm
thoroughly enjoying myself he's still a
job I've got a job to do I've got a job
to just to smash it out of the park for
those 60 minutes the time afterwards is
reflection on how good the job was or
how good the I don't want to call it a
job because when I first started I
wanted to do it for free it's just he
just so happens to pay now but the
performance I like to think about
afterwards and be like yeah that was it
we listened to your set back ever - no
no can just remember we've obviously we
have video content for every gig I know
which kind of drops have been the
biggest though I and I always I'll be
like yeah that one was good you made
sure got a video of that there it there
is a period of your post work reflection
that allows you to iterate on improving
that the right so I was literally today
of podcasts gone out with James from
podcast Co where I talked about mine and
Rogan says he he never ever listens to
his podcasts back which is interesting
because he always listens to his
stand-up routines back and I think it's
because first off he's gonna be so busy
that after having spent three hours
recording with someone then spending
another 300 he's a little bit higher
your own voice yes but I think the other
thing is that he he finds podcasting to
be so well within his domain of
competence that he doesn't need to but
for me at the moment as someone who's
still trying to improve and iterate on
that I think that reflection period is
really really important but you touched
on some it real important she's I think
a lot of DJ's don't consider their job a
job yeah and I mean I'm telling you that
I am the guy I'm a fantastic example of
who you need to impress I got four
nights a week in Newcastle either you
know multiple rooms of those there's
probably 100 grunt of wages going out to
DJ's between all the different rooms all
the different bits so I want a person
who's going to turn up on time I want
someone who's gonna put some social
media of during the day without me
asking yeah without me having a [ __ ]
go my mate would you mind [ __ ] this
is out book yes I think that's kind of
initially Danny's sort of appeal to DJ
and was very much just an amplified
party lifestyle and the fact that he was
but I would say never I would still
never belay or sack it off for not do
the best job I could I would never drink
myself into oblivion and do a really
well I would but I'd still be able to
perform I'd still be able to do I'd
still be able to do the set but I think
that was sort of that you couldn't DJ
etiquette that sort of those lower level
basics of proof
lism it seems to be absent for quite a
few DJ's know something I sort of
observed and I think even you in the
early days because you had that and that
was just because you wanted to be
everyone's friend and you were that
larger-than-life personality I think
particularly DJ's don't realize how far
that goes you know yes you need to be a
technically good DJ and obviously be
able to read a crowd and all of those
sort of fundamentals but if you're not a
nice person or you know you're late or
you're not posting on social media
you're not supporting an event people
aren't gonna want to book you I mean the
DJ skills are what get you through the
door there's this blog post that someone
said to me the other day that talks
about why nice guys thinks that think
that girls should like them it's like
hang on a second you think that because
you're kind to your mum and you're
always on time and you always put
kissing the girls should like you
they're like [ __ ] you you do not know
what girls like there is a man out there
who can do all of that and he plays the
guitar play the guitar yeah so you've
gone back to like just just been that
happy friendly jolly guy I was on the
phone to somebody but the our sky won't
working in our bedroom last night I know
it wasn't because I've had to put some
150 I don't know if I put on my star
even if you've seen it so I was on the
phone to someone from Sky and you were
cracking a few jokes like he thought you
were a hero like a a fully guy and he
walked quite entertaining to fair it was
like it was a bit of breath of fresh air
that somebody that was sorting you like
fixing you sky was actually like putting
a bit of personality into the car and it
was like a so what what were you trying
to watch when it's not working about my
bar and then we got talking I was like
hi where are you from in the Northeast
could tell he was from the Northeast was
like I knew cuz I was like playing there
tomorrow he's like where I was like
digitally was like we did you are my god
because I'll tell you what I'll do you
deal if you sought me out if I fix your
sky tonight you put me and my friends on
in VIP detail tomorrow night that was a
easy deal my dog yeah
and Rebecca mom mrs. Rebecca said as
soon as she was like as soon as she
heard that she went my god you'll make
friends with anyone and I was like
that's that falls back into this it's
just like demeanor why would you
undocked why would you no I totally
respect people that don't want to meet
well as our friends but just I don't
know I just attract friends I just like
I think that the point that you've made
there is you are at a competitive
advantage if you can yes right because
it's just especially in this in this
industry it's people money you know like
and the we touched on it before like you
have to be able to deliver the product
I'll happily suck a nice DJ who [ __ ] a
DJ but I'll pick over to DJ's that are
the same I'll pick the one that's
pushing the social media I picked the
one that does everything else but as
we've said at the very beginning a lot
of DJ's look at all of the ancillary
[ __ ] all the stuff around the outside
but it's like are you releasing a
monthly mix probably a pretty good play
if I was a DJ first thing I would do
would be to have like build up a mix
following kick sharpens my skills keeps
me relevant with people and you
searching for new music all the times
you got just put the same stuff on every
mix you've got a constantly be hunting
for new stuff the foundation of kind of
why I put into play with Danny in the
very beginning was your or your
personality is great and you know
musically people know who you are and
they were watching on Fridays and
Saturdays potentially Sundays what are
they hungover and scrolling through
their phone but that midweek between
Monday and Thursday what you doing to
grab people's attention like are you
engaging with those people are you
putting out the mix like as a DJ you're
meant to be there resource of
information for music like how you
keeping them engaged how are you like
letting them know about music so a
monthly mix was a great foundation for
us and then yeah awesome week topper
three weeks three weeks is a week out
when you win my soundcloud was at its
height SoundCloud dropped off everyone's
kind of gone towards Wi-Fi playlists now
rather than actual DJ mixes you can
still get good players on DJ mixes
people still do want them and still like
for them like them but the word
SoundCloud was just like the one and as
I could see everything progressing I was
like where I can pull out two mixes this
is gone up a little bit out tomorrow and
I was like because I was just sat at
home just hunting for music like even
even when I was in Mali or I'd wake up
and the lads would like like go past on
their own on their parents past a
restaurant and beat the harm laughing
and joking so I was sat staring at my
laptop and they were going to sunbathe
for four hours and I'd be sat there but
did it feel that work no knocks I was
enjoying it and some bathing's Bari is
another thing that keeps on coming back
in a lot of conversations I'm having
your competitive advantage in life is
doing what for you feels like fun but
for everyone else feels like work yay
that is the easiest way to find and for
me it's this you know I've got work
tonight till three in the morning which
is even later than you depending on
whether not you're drinking you've got
to go back to Leeds
so you know I've got that tonight but I
I hustle you to come and do this podcast
because I'd have felt remiss by cut ah I
want to know what it's like to walk out
on stage you're her father so for me I
am a competitive advantage for other
people for whom this would be your
lovely but this would be [ __ ] torture
right I'm enjoying it and so does
everyone that's listening but some
people wouldn't want that this
conversation yeah even some of the audio
but that's just you taking not taking
advantage but that's you like yeah
taking advantage of an opportunity that
that could arise for both of us it's
just you it's the one it's I would do
this I would do this even if there was
no opportunity coming off the back of it
if I would do this and not put it out
it's the what you love and I think
literally like a big part of my job is I
said this you at the start of the year
but that feeling that sensation that you
got walking on stage at the first direct
arena my job through and through is to
facilitate as many of those moments as
possible this year and beyond like the
fact that you get to do what you love if
I can make that happen time and time and
time again that's wholeheartedly why I
exist that is my job role in its
entirety the same for you the fact that
you're able to do what you love like why
wouldn't you do that over
over again and the thing as well is on
top of that your this bringing the
example I got from James clear gather
atomic cupboards and he was talking
about Steffi Graf I'm a Steffi Graf the
tennis player Steffi Graf was you know
that was just a shock and she's still
alive no I'm not dead just sure I don't
know why would that's a weird thing
happened if anyone knows whether or not
Steffi Graf Spee know it was the other
one that got stabbed on car tennis
player is this with a new imagine this
done you know what she could Monica
Seles
got stabbed on Carla they will have
anyone know if Monica Seles anything so
yes she's about 12 years old she's in
the German youth tennis set up they do
an assessment two broad spectrums one of
them is capability athletically and the
other one is mindset and it turns out
that Steffi Graf was the highest rated
in terms of her technical ability she
was also the highest rate in terms of
love for the sport so it's like hang in
a second let's say that you have all the
talent that Steffi Graf does she'll
still outwork you and it won't even feel
like work yeah you know I mean like
that's a formidable person to come up
against you know it's so aside from
managing Danni also like consult with
other people and the one thing that's
been consistent for her it is if you are
an entrepreneur or creative or someone
where you know you're putting something
out there to some people you have to
have your way and if you don't love what
you do like you will end up giving up
and I think the factors like it hasn't
always been easy for you but the fact
that you just want to DJ and you
absolutely love it for and through
that's what gives you the consistency
select continue going even when it
hasn't been ideal hasn't been as smooth
as people may perceive it like I just
think if you want to be successful like
having your way in terms of you know
really really loving what you do that's
what we need I've said out of like if I
stop to enjoy you mix up dad stop yeah
don't just carry on doing it just to pay
the bills I'll go get y'all Blackie's I
wouldn't do it making me miserable
because it's made me so happy
over the years why would I want butter
go down like stay on a high like stay
leave just let your pocket park that I
don't enjoy it anymore do a retirement
gig make lots of money and then and then
do and then god what an exacta house you
know whatever come whatever comes next
so ever well there's that Nietzsche
quote which is a man with a strong
enough why I can bear anyhow you know
there you go I'm happy to go through
[ __ ] fire and brimstone
if kind of the challenge is worth it so
you know you've been nights where you've
been basically no sleep getting on a
plane
[ __ ] strapping your eye mask I've
seen photos of you you look like you
look like a Teletubby that's some tech
that's some tech project so I'm gonna
break the fourth wall a little bit to
the people that are listening Danny's
been teasing me with his travel hacks on
me I've got the best black heart even
share with you cuz if they start doing
it onto it we won't be a ruin it for the
rest okay so there's a new I'll tell you
after you know and I want you to be able
to give us some that you're prepared to
make right sleeping on planes bearing in
mind I used to be so anxious on a flight
that I just had to cling onto the seat
in front and couldn't couldn't let go
until we'd stopped for average four
hours seven eight flights a week you can
imagine how painful that was to start
with now the whole summer last summer
87 flights I was awake for no more than
15 minutes on each flight what do you do
what's your process oh you know good
headphones that go over the ear what do
you use
I've just got beats where I soft soft
grey beats that go over the top so make
sure the softest the in your ear you
could wake up cuz it's her in the inside
area ear pods don't work I love my ear
pods but they don't work for this so
over the top of the year I you just use
the the headspace free trial just loop
the ten
the 10 meditation 10-minute may be seen
as they've got her as the sleep noise
which is like white noise but for sleep
meridah it's like differently our levels
of hums and I have that to go sleep it's
the rain more sleep aid okay okay so
you've got that under a mask and I must
that doesn't touch the lids your eyes
what I was used you know you got it from
it's an Amazon room but it's like a
round pot yeah goes around if it touches
your eyelids you wake up with really dry
eyes in your eyes off stuck together
okay it doesn't touch your eyelid you
literally wake up and you eventually
wake up and you're like fresh and ready
to go and I like for people that are
just listening they can like furry
goggles aren't they but with something
yeah yeah yeah they look like like a
World War World War one pilot goggles
yeah and I've got a like a it's like
it's not a breathing mask it'll help you
breathe where it just stops my planes
are literally the most unhealthy air in
the world it's just all so you've got
lie of it one of those that Clips around
and just you know where you got your
yeah just you can you remember the brand
of oh no no no I'll try and get you to
send it to me if I can find it in them
being the show notes yeah yeah so you
got that what about um cushion for the
neck yeah you've got all of a saw I've
got the same one in it the same one
about for like three years now and it's
it needs a wash it means a good one good
watch no but I've never found one that's
better you've got to make sure when it's
clipped together you can't touch that
year on your shoulders because otherwise
you end up like I would be far without
what I mean like oh my god how am I
gonna how am I gonna DJ I might push in
my head yeah and like oh my like what
have I done to myself are you really -
shoulders yeah okay so we got that what
about so posture
what about seat choice choices anchor an
aisle in for a window and for the front
that's a hack within itself that's
that's a hack and a separate
conversation which all speeds you after
this secret in football if you booked
her if you booked a seat towards the
front of the plane it isn't as turbulent
as the back
that's interesting you don't get shaken
as well if you think about it the wings
are there this the wings are there left
and right your first point is the first
bit
it's the wings that are going up and
down not the front of the plane so as
the wings are going up and down the
backs moving modern from that's
interesting so you always get worse to
get into the back of the plane
I might it just made that up but in my
head it works and I always have even if
you may always have some I oh no I think
that's true I I've liked but I
researched already that he waked up
someone will call it so but I've I've
been on loads of flights at the front of
being find loads of flights at the back
and the back flights are always a lot
like they feel a lot bumpier even like
when there's no turbulence like you know
when the door of the seatbelt sign on
even you're allowed to walk around the
back of the plane definitely balances
well what's the most efficient way to
get through an airport it is worth
paying to pump 50 anna in advance for a
FasTrak security ok straight through if
you book it well in advance ease to 2.50
it up with anyone that's like easyJet or
no no you booked it direct through the
airport right oh yeah I've been on I've
been on flights before the if I didn't
if I didn't have that visible 2% miss my
flight
like I suppose the problem is it's all
well and good I can turn up to pretty
much any flight departing from you
Castle cos from here it is 10 minutes
the air the airport I can leave here an
hour and 15 before I need to depart even
with whole blockage and be on the plane
fine unless there's a key word security
yeah yeah and if there's a key word
security you done [ __ ] like my life if
you if there's a cute secure a all you
do is run to the front of god I'm about
to miss my flight and I'll let you go
straight through okay there's a bit
about other stuff what about you taking
water on board you making sure if you go
every airport now got up at the other
side so just taken into bottle plastic
war if you did up at the other side as
soon as you go through security there's
now a drinking it up really in every UK
air part here that's interest laughter I
don't know if they've legally had to put
it in but they've you've know
every when I got them through now they
have one of those little so you've got
like a girl like a good to the chili
yeah just take you take a ball to be
found like so in a rush I'm not even
like that prepared some things yeah I'm
just like right grab it well what was
free on the plane hmm you want to have
it yeah I mean you want the VA bottle
that you've got with you all time yeah
I've got a good one it's already been on
a life hacks book WH Smith versus boots
if you go into WH Smiths
they've got buttered soaring loaves and
it's fifty pounds or less a meal deal
and they've actually got I think a more
premium selection of sandwiches boots
that's what I'm saying sorry I'm stuffed
responsibilities what else so what else
have you got from you've got to got to
got to got to make sure your liquids in
a bag because that could save you twenty
five minutes there don't make any
mistakes
no what depends have how many times you
travel if you travel a lot I know if my
laptop has to come out I know my phone
charger has to come out that's that's
always good to have a phone charger to
take on the plane this if your iPhone's
not the latest one they make sure it
don't last for hours so always have like
a phone tragedy twenty quid for the
massive ones I mean it charges you
phones six rates a lifetime yeah I could
literally take that on on the road for
four days and they'll just keep charging
I'm going to Athens this weekend for my
birthday and I'm taking an external
charge and I don't need to worry about
having a plug socket okay the only thing
else that I need to chop my Kindle or
last for five weeks against a monstrous
and a BAE where you got your external
charger you don't even care about what
the power port is I just bought one for
my laptop stick on a lot think wooden
external charge of yeah yeah no way does
that exist
yeah it's further with us for the road I
just by how many laptop charge and tried
it yet what does it say must have told
you how many laptop charges do you go
you charge it one I don't know I just
went for the biggest one that demos Dave
obviously knows about carrying camera
equipment through and if it's over a
hundred watt you're not allowed to take
you through secure if they spot me at
home
so I knew that it wasn't allowed to be
more than 95 or sighs Justin I just got
the 100 watt 1 which was the like that
was the biggest one but it's about this
big it's not even that ever it's got a
fan built into it to keep it here it's
like it's not even that heavy some
couple piece of kit that though I mean
do you run out of battery on your on
your laptop that much yeah on the road
yeah not well not well with my old
laptop that lasts about 15 weeks I've
got a new laptop that my last ones still
and what about fur on the road then
let's say that you drive in you got any
cool travel hacks for for driving around
on the road like if you got a preference
for most most service stations of up
beat rustlers offs are baby milk free
microwaves so you can actually take
decent food on the road you don't have
to just leave on meal deals so you could
potentially pre cook all of your stuff
yeah he cooks some sauce I do I've got
it I've got it in the bag here yeah well
I use my 50 no I don't know Road tasks
when you're with me all the time or
driving nice how to not pay for parking
drive at night
drive at night man I mean I'd anyone
that's between the hours of like 7 a.m.
and 9:00 and then 3:30 p.m. and 5:30 the
roads are just or leads is still a easy
really can't move especially around the
arena as well I'm guessing they're not
even the arena the whole of the season
is just just maddening my my parents
live ten miles away from me on the
opposite side to Leeds
it's half an hour in no traffic and hour
and 45 minutes it is busy I live in
London issues long yeah yes get the
train train to LA no have you ever seen
the traffic in LA yes it's a it's beyond
anything you've ever seen like and if
this thing as well as it's the so many
lanes leads
mind blowing that you're on a motorway
and you're are there must be a crash
your hair do you like no this is what
traffic is like you're a nose to tail
for miles it's like like Dubai it's like
a woman point the motorway the freeway
in Dubai is 11
lanes each way wide but the thing with
Dubai this is what blew me away is that
is a city which has been designed for
millions of people to live there so you
can be doing 70 miles an hour 90 seconds
before you reach your destination in the
middle of the city and then you'll peel
off on this like real weird spaghetti
and then it just deposits you on like
the palm jumeirah beach or whatever nila
how the [ __ ] that I was on a motorway
two seconds ago yeah yeah yeah that's
good
so or if you take a wrong turn you've
got a 17 mile detour to get back to
eight so there's a little bit
challenging you know you don't [ __ ] up
with that tight Yorkshire one coming out
here so we've been to divide me and my
Mississippi to dip I like fall times
though not the last time you went the
time you Father bear in mind you can get
attacked it from the airport to any
hotel in Dubai for about fifteen quid
it's not actually not that interesting
out really cheap out there it's insane
it's so cheap and there's even like the
local taxes are even cheaper than uber
so we got there and I was like right no
we're gonna exploit night I was well it
was pitch black
we decided to get the Train which it was
it was probably about six o'clock seven
o'clock it had gotten dark but it wasn't
like the middle of the night the train
was still running I was like right we'll
get dropped off at the bottom of the
Parliament just walk up to 5 which is
the hotel we're staying now so only 100
yards or something got there and I was
like oh my god there's form of two a's
in between here and the bottom of the
palm there's no footpaths you can't walk
anywhere so as i do believe it how are
you the flag attacks you don't feel like
you need to go there and i looked and we
were literally at the bottom of the palm
from the hotel from from the airport on
the train bottom of the palm flag down a
taxi and we were at what i thought it
was gonna be to a 300-yard walk from the
train station it was a seven mile car
journey to get there because you can't
just go straight you have to go like
round and then don't go too far cause
she owned upon that mile away and then
back on yourself they look the part and
then you
to go a mile past five to turn back and
come back down the problem to get to it
like he's mad I mean go to Dubai don't
be tight just just pay for taxes she was
cheap yeah you're right and so we want
to touch on some mental health stuff
today as well yeah yeah have you guys
been having sort of many discussions
about this recently is there been any we
have a lot in life anyway just yeah we
want to write a book called how no know
how to survive in a world full of idiots
yeah as an as an idiot no no no rather
say - so how do I survive in a world
full of idiots how long have you got
with our our most common thing that we
say to each other is that common sense
is the least common thing in the world
like it's actually so ironic because
common sense is not common at all give
me an example of some uncommon common
sense how to undo a lightbulb 80% of
people that not change a lightbulb
they definitely got that from I can't I
mean they net things are a little bit
like non-logical like the way that you
put a bayonet lightbulb in what else
what else is uncommon I know loads of
people that don't know this - type 2
light bulb - time to fix it yeah yeah I
didn't know like people are buying
houses like grow novels 25 year olds
that don't know that was two different
types of light bulb there's people
listening now they're going let's do
let's do the vendor healthy that's what
we've been thinking about recently have
you been talking about well it's
obviously massive in eggs it's probably
the biggest buzz word other if buzz
means that it's like a positive thing or
not based he's so it's so talked about
in life in general in the media that the
mental health is this big problem that I
think I've never actually sat there and
like googled how do I not have men
like everybody's got mental health I've
just put some things in place that I
think work to make sure I don't have any
problems more like well I like the
feeling of nostalgia it's good to throw
back to childhood I've got a bicycle I
do like loads of bike rides and that to
me is not just a bit of fitness that to
me is like I finish the bike ride and
I'm like how are amazing I felt like a
big kid again it's like the feeling of
going way when you're a kid going down a
hill like that is a feeling of like the
best not the not that your life might be
bad now but like the most trouble-free
easy calm happy times your life is just
being a kid when you have no worries so
putting things in place that bring you
back to LA I think I just it's a tiny
little thing that you can do to to make
yourself happier love you Casey we've
been thinking about to do with mental
health recently um I think gratitude is
something that's come very very
underestimated in terms of how it can
benefit you meant off I just think it's
a good foundation and I don't know
anyone who is like happy or like I seem
really how it's like a productive mental
health setting that doesn't actively or
proactively practice I gratitude how
have you instantiate that have you
structured that into your life
six-minute very recommendation from your
podcast yes yeah that there's there's
other little things but I think yeah
just by proactively taking measures to
to bizarre if you if you don't have a
formalized structure like you now do
with the six-minute diary or anything
else if you're not innately built to be
grateful for things and to be reflective
in that way and focus on the good
it is a real change very very drastic
difference between the two and I don't
know about you but
I think I felt like five or six and now
so I've been doing it like three years
and now I find myself doing things and
thinking about things in a way that
gratitude has taught me to so I was
losing perception yeah it's just it's
entirely how you choose to look at
something and you can be presented with
something and the difference in mindset
between how I choose to look at
something be it from you know ways this
teaching me and you know am I looking it
from a position where say for example
you people be very fruit Alma it's quite
easy to sit there and blame that trauma
for you know how bad is make you feel
but at the same time that trauma is also
responsible for all the good things that
have coming out of it and literally just
by being in great and not saying that
you need to be grateful for trauma but
being grateful for the experiences and
the lessons that you will learn from
that nothing has changed in that dynamic
you know it's just choosing to look at
it from an entirely different
perspective
couldn't agree more man yeah that's here
you are very much in control of your
response to any situation and that's I'm
reading month search for meaning again
for at the third time at the moment
Victor Frankel's book this guy Holocaust
survivor who also created school of
psychology called logotherapy and the
quote from it is the final thing that
can never be taken from any man is his
ability to respond however he chooses to
any given situation and that's it right
you can be in the worst situation in a
you know ash wits but you can still
choose how you respond someone say
something suit to you that is a freedom
that can't be taken away nobody can be
you can't say oh I'm gonna fly away I'm
not bird there are certain things you
can't do but there is always something
you can't and I think touch switching a
victim hood mentality makes a big
difficult vehicle I think as well like
even with Danny social media you know I
think as I said before if you are
creative in any sense of the word
you're obviously put in some sort of
creation to the worst service you can
have people that like yet people that
don't like it how you choose to respond
to that ultimately is major influence on
your own mental health so Danny you're
having people saying that they don't
like his DJ no they don't
he's missing it's not quite as nice as
though it's nice not again how Danny
refuses to respond to this well I'm
laughing about it I'm laughing at people
I'm not laughing at them I'm just
laughing about the fact that people can
be so offended by a combination of
chords and sounds to think that I may
have to type that your music is as bad
as AIDS or cancer like that's to me nuts
that's hilarious how can you actually
like how is someone's brain that stupid
to make those links like music I don't
like you could just switch it off and be
happy about switching it off instead you
have to write let me get my phone tell
everyone how much I don't like it like
that's so sad that just it shows how
much you're an unhappy person you have
to be to do that like I think it's
everyone has these thoughts right the
sort of burble below the surface it's
wind up with jealousy or envy or genuine
just dislike for something that you do
the problem is that social media rewards
things that we either agree with or
things that outrageous yeah that's one
of the reasons I think why every
conversation now is getting polarized to
the extremes you have people that are
grouping in the spheres of awareness on
both ends of the spectrum
and then you have the people that just
come out with shock tactics
there's no rationality on social media I
don't think people were able to have
conversations Eva
it's literally I agree with you and I
think there's such an eagerness as well
for people just to say the first thing
that comes to their head or jump on
something that sometimes people sit
there and plan it out for hours how to
be the fullness that can be to get the
most likes not even the funny is just
then a swatch can get regular what's
gonna get no much likes to don't really
think you'd be surprised man I think
maybe some people that have that trolley
mentality may constantly have is this an
opportunity to troll yes in the back of
their mind yeah I don't think that any
of the stuff that you see like that the
real vitriol comments I don't think any
of them are considered
I think they're all visceral I thought a
lot of Tyler's like the doesn't mean I'm
either they're not even like let me just
say it is just a thing and this is for
never in human history have all of the
things that we've said been recorded
ever right now this conversation should
if it wasn't for technology just between
us three and two guys behind the camera
yeah that's what it should be but now we
have technology that allows us to do
that and you have the lack of friction
that means that you can say something 24
hours a day that is reordered forever on
the internet you know and we're seeing
this so the Caroline Flack situation
that's occurred this weekend the Sun had
put a particular article up about her
and then as soon as Italy the and they
took the article down as soon as they
realized they could get some and that's
I think I think like particular media
publications like that the fact is I
think interests other than a very good
quote about this where he said you know
people don't really care as Denzel
Washington was like people don't really
care if it's true or not they just want
to be first like see it and say it so I
think particularly for the Sun newspaper
is what headline is gonna sell the most
article is it doesn't matter if it's
truth because they just need people to
read it and they know they can get away
with a small apology off the woods it's
a lot worse now that it used to be like
there's so much clickbait out there like
people read the headlines and go oh my
god it's gonna snow sheep tomorrow sheep
are gonna drop from the ground and money
what I'll actually say is the article
will be about there was some wallpaper
of sheep falling from the sky that's
actually a picture but the headlines
gripped people and sometimes they don't
even read that deep into it just like
because this foam I believe it
everything that sunlight like everything
that's all why didn't someone do a troll
of this where they said like this huge
big article that got Reshard tons and I
said eighty-nine percent of people don't
read past the first first headline of an
article then the rest of it was
explaining how that was a lie people
that grab a link and reshare it yeah but
yeah you know it's it's challenging for
me to see the things that I do online so
you're someone who's got exposed to more
incoming social media than most normal P
we'll do what some of the strategies you
use to deal with that is it just ignore
it like Casey Casey see yeah I'm so
outsource it to someone how do not see
it I don't want to see it whether it's
positive or not like I'm not putting it
out there for people if I read a hundred
comments oh my god it's amazing I love
you like although that makes me feel
amazing that's not the reason I'm doing
it I'm putting it out there because I
really enjoy it and I want it to
continue this journey that I'm on it's
like so for me to not see the positive
comments means that I don't see the
negative comments that's absolutely
factually what's about to pay and what's
at the point I think you go back to what
you said in the very very beginning
about you know I think the real support
from Danny's following comes from the
people to come see him in the shows and
the fact that people they're
appreciating what he does firsthand like
that's where you can get your
satisfaction there's not from people
like commenting or anything like that
but the fact that people are willing to
spend their hard-earned money and see
you as a source of entertainment and you
know they're there supporting you at
your shows etc that's a much easier
metric for you to gauge how successful
your you are whatever person sitting
there reading loads of comments of how
many lecture yeah for sure
I used to reply to like if something was
bad doll I didn't agree with it I did
you like a few years ago I let the reply
like I remember once and this is what
kind of changed it I won't say where
which club it was but I was playing in a
club and someone the end messaged me on
they were on snapchat I wasn't even on
like Instagram or anything it was a
private message on snapchat saying you
fat bastard I've just paid to take as if
I have just paid a taint a tenner to
come in here and see you you're getting
stabbed when you leave here nice message
and I replied saying bearing in mind his
username was his full name
I replied as such ascending I showed it
straight to the manager who was stood
next to me and he went right he's banned
from here I'll find out who he is put
watch whatever will make sure his name
again so I literally replied scene
congratulations May you've just great
self bummed for life and that was it
that's all I replied saying
the next day he's screenshotted that and
put it on Twitter saying my reply input
what he'd said
and then his comment was all I did was
call him a fat bastard look at the
response ha ha ha violently like he said
that he didn't make it upset and that
you'd got him all right
yeah yeah yeah it was something like oh
yeah pull up the screenshot la but he
said all I said was I didn't like his
set or something like that and my reply
was completely not to that whatsoever
did you get your screenshot and then put
in the car he couldn't quote tweet with
the screenshot then so what did I what
could I do
yeah and it vanished by then anyway I
was literally like [ __ ] like I think he
only I think he got like 300 likes his
actual thing but to me that was 300
people that hated me and we're happy to
see my demise and from that day I was
like I can't see this stuff is it's
gonna stop me from doing something I
love because some people that are not
benefiting me in any way anyway so if
you care about the people that thought
of what you do like that's the wrong
energy you don't need to focus your
energy on battling the people that are
never gonna love what you do all benefit
you career anyway are being like also
like being sore authentically vulnerable
in the sense of appreciating that you
know not everyone is gonna love what you
do and you're okay with that
yeah like the journey that we're kind of
on is like there's obviously people that
aren't gonna like it but there are
thousands and thousands of people who do
love it and it's let's focus on mistake
not the piously yeah those are the
people who are paying to support you
like steak let's entertain those people
do it do a very very good job at it area
I think that's you focus your energy on
that it's totally different perceptions
you touched on something like AC about
the people who follow the content
favorite content creator or DJ whatever
it is the ones that buying their music
they're going to their shows they're
doing whatever I say you know there's
been some people over the last few years
have been like man like I've taken a lot
of value from the podcast thank you very
much
I'd love to buy you a gift or whatever
is at them honestly honestly the best
thing you can do is just share it with
like if you get me one more Serb mmm
that's that's eat so you know for the
people that listening I said did this
tweet that went a bit viral the other
day that said um gasps your friends up
it blows my mind how many people will
support a Rihanna by pure collaboration
but won't like them you their friends
new business on Facebook
it's like if you want to feel like
you're helping a content creator just do
the thing stick to the thing that they
do like help them gas them up in that
sort of always suggested to your friends
yeah because I think you have a unique
mindset with this Danni in that you
don't need that is not confirmation or
validation but you don't need gassing up
from your fans because you you kind of
have faith that they're there for you
yeah um but there are people out there
and I'm one of them
who I really am still early on in the
journey with regards to the podcast and
I take so much pleasure and so much
motivation from seeing those messages
yeah but for me it's still an important
part of it too I mean especially there'd
be people out there most projects or
solo projects it's hard to find someone
else it's on that same path with you and
with that in mind it's like if you like
what someone does message them tell them
like remove the friction because you've
just spent the last 20 minutes scrolling
through Instagram stories of people you
hate yeah and you you like well why
don't you just [ __ ] support your guy
like now I do don't think that I'm like
I think I'm above reading people's
messages or anything like that because I
will go through every single message my
point is you don't so he was two or
three days later once all the bad ones
of being hidden just Salada
like it's not that it even bother me
that much is just why even see anything
when you have the opportunity now he
likes that I've seen I've seen a video
before the DJed released he was playing
Ministry of Sound in London and he'd
made a bootleg like a drum and bass
bootleg of a big a big house tune and he
put up a video two hours later it was on
a hundred thousand views like it was
going he'd not put a penny sponsor on it
it was flying
and swallow negative comment to delete
the video clean getting to him too much
he'll say despite the fact that now put
about a million views that could have
changed his life change his career that
could have but for someone to go viral
equally as many people like my 80 in
music especially a song it's got to get
slated to make it go viral an equal
number of people have got to share it
because they hate it as like it because
that doubles the amount of views so that
there was the amount of exposure it's
getting Johnny the guy that usually sat
where you are Casey's got a does PPC and
like advertising Facebook ads every day
and his synopsis for all of that is
clicks or clicks yeah like which is the
old adage it's better to be in here but
I've literally only saw this this video
was gonna get a million views the speed
it was going up the speed the views were
going apart and he couldn't take and
better Chris he couldn't take they're
not the criticisms it was like gnats
like nasty stuff but because he hated it
so much hey but if you an agent could go
to somebody and go I got a million views
in two days we should get that guy we
should give him a cracker of ether rocks
warts or whatever it might be so how do
you deal Casey obviously it's you that
is kind of in the vanguard you've taken
point on shady social media comments it
must be challenging for you to see
people online saying bad things about
your clients our friend now you know you
don't see it like it like I see yeah I'd
you know in the early stages I think
because even I was quite protective of
what we were trying to achieve I was
like okay what we doing wrong why don't
people like what he's doing you know and
I think maybe it was in experience
because there's no there's no rulebook
no one gives you a rulebook that says
these are the rules like if people start
slagging you off you're making enough
noise that you're actually being
successful so there's no rulebook so
you're like why do these people not like
I I don't I don't dislike them I don't
know who they are like way and I think
because it was a because we was putting
a lot of content out there was you know
that there's no consistency there's no
theme there's no there's nothing was
measurable in terms of what would get
good comments or what would get bad
comments it was just at the mercy of the
you know the years Internet yeah the
internet um but now I even put videos up
deliver at least a troll certain crowd
stuff but I think when you can do that
when you can get to that stage I've got
a front for Michael malleus who was on a
couple of weeks ago and he's been on
Rogan five times and he is you know Loki
from the Avengers
yes but he is Loki for American politics
and Twitter in general and his approach
is just so he tweeted the other day
Hitler built the Berlin Wall Trump wants
to build a wall you do the maths
hit that didn't build the Berlin run but
he just like they such bet and the
Berlin Wall trended in America because
because of this tweet yes well I won't
say it like that I would try to get
yourself to that stage I think and you
don't take yourself too seriously that's
that that's the real sweet spot by faith
for me I just I really couldn't care
less I think that's why I'm probably the
best place but like Danny's happy I'm
happy
Danny's doing well I consider us both to
be doing well I don't think there's a
quote brené Brown refers to it by a
Teddy Roosevelt gross like I can't
remember it word for word it's like it's
not the I can't remember exactly but
it's basically saying if you're not in
the arena taking pot I don't care for
your opinion and I think for those
people you know unless you're someone
who's value Y opinion unless you're
doing something similar or you know
putting yourself out there or you're
actually trying to achieve something
great I don't care for your opinion so
for anyone who has something to say
about Danny's opinion or Danny's career
if I value their opinion they would have
come and said it directly to me and we
would be having a conversation it would
be constructive but for someone who's
just posting nonsense online I couldn't
care less it doesn't affect how much I
get paid yeah I'm with you guys
mm-hmm so yeah it's not gonna deter him
from going out now now we're definitely
don't see you don't affect your
happiness but I saw Lamar you know is it
a takeaway for anyone I've been trying
to push as many people that list
as possible to that don't do a project
start the business that you want
whatever it is follow a passion that you
have because you can do it with such low
investment in terms of time and
resources the podcast I did with James
from podcast Co which I'll put in the
show notes below as well that has my
full working process from the gear I
used to the filters that I have to the
mastering program to the way I upload to
my hosting platform because nothing
would make me happy them for someone
else to go and do this like the internet
it's a very very big place and how
rewarding would that be for you to
someone else go and then be like hey man
like noni did you make a podcast I
enjoyed I'm now making a podcast because
of you there hey you know how many
people might have listened to this
hopefully today who are like oh do you
know what it is like my DJing career was
kind of a bit wishy-washy but you know
done Ian Casey said give it a [ __ ]
shot and really go after it with energy
and pop mixtapes out I'm gonna commit
for the next twelve months I'm gonna do
a mixed day per month and I'm gonna go
around give it out to people or whatever
the [ __ ] it is nicely hope seeing people
do well especially when they really
really really deserve it there was a
there's a lot who probably listen to
this truth came to a DJ workshop I did
four years ago it was 14 you have to be
16 to go on the workshop and he's mum
booked him on didn't say anything and I
was I was like there was no problem she
she just said not can I stay with him
for the day and literally like shoving
DJ routines and helping helping people
do stuff he was for Decca mixing at 14
years old at the start of this session I
was like I don't have to make something
more complicated up for this guy and
he's now just turn 18 we've kept in such
sins he's being like how can up he's
been almost saddened like I can't get
any gigs I can't get any opportunities
on your child I was like yes yes he was
easily a child 16 chill out he's 17
chill out
now he's 18 just old enough to go to
clubs I've gotta finally allowed to get
into the club that you're that you're
signing you're not getting booked
yes I got a phone call saying I need a
resident for a Friday and I at this
ba-ba-ba-ba he went and did the set at
this bar he's now got three residences a
week and he's on five hundred quid a
week DJ a new factory is 80 like more
money or the 100 percent would not have
got that gig if it wasn't for him
showing his enthusiasm be nice being
hungry to progress and keeping him
talked to me and he didn't pest me all
the time he was just nice and you know
and now he's like now he's just straight
away as an 18 year old walked into twin
like 25 grand a year's worth of gigs but
the beautiful thing about networking and
this is why I am glad that my background
over the last 13 years of being a
nightclub promoter it lends you toward
going networking first and the beautiful
thing about networks is there the only
thing which don't share when you
multiply them that should I mean yeah
like they don't divide they multiply yes
like and you get to continue you build
out all of these different stuff there
was a guy who sent me an email like six
months into when I side the podcast who
was a bunch of book recommendations and
said I really think that you would this
would be a good guess and a couple of
other things and Jordan is now one of my
best mates now he books people on at the
show he helped me source guests George
McGill sent me another one saying hey
Matt I know that you like Chrome browser
extensions here's a list of them by the
way if you ever much has to let me know
his episodes that I ended up recording
with him last year at the first and
second most played ever bigger than
Aubrey Marcus bigger than James clearer
bigger than Robert Green bigger than
Christoph being at everything and he's
just some fella and all it cost him was
a deer well only cost was a deer you
know and reaching out to people like
that it can change everything I did that
at 17 so prior to working with Danny and
LED before I even got involved in my
life I just messaged a guy I work at his
club
and emission Co no just saying I wanted
to learn about and then I got an
internship in the my Club in central
London just from that message as a 17
year old like you have nothing to lose
from a skin laughing just having the
vulnerability to put yourself out there
like what what's the alternative
I can't remember I can't remember who
was it told me the story the businesses
this was on another episode where there
was this young American black guy who
lived in quite poor neighborhood and he
wanted to work out how to be rich went
around knocking on just thought I'm
gonna knock on the doors in the richest
neighborhood in town
second person whose door Enoch tom was
the Acting CEO of IBM who gave him an
internship there and there he knew that
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like people that go
out of their way and make things happen
people will think that I was looking so
here's the thing Taylor Pearson who's
coming on in a couple of weeks time and
I just keep consuming his content Taylor
Pearson taught me for anyone that's
interested he's an absolutely
[ __ ] lack cannot believe the
sort of stuff this guy puts out and he's
got this this post he's written about
procrastination which is just beautiful
and he says the thing about
procrastination is the reason we do it
is because we're scared of failure we
don't undertake the thing that we want
to try and do in case we might fail at
it but the weird thing about
procrastination is that by trying to
inoculate ourselves from failing
publicly we guarantee that we will fail
privately yeah like okay maybe you
didn't [ __ ] up in public but by doing
nothing nothing happened like you can
only benefit from doing something in
taking action yeah so you know I think
that that action first approach is a
really good way to go look gentlemen we
made it there we go
it's dirty and Kasey why should people
go they want to find out your music they
want to check out your socials when it's
done et DJ on everything some clubs as
well something that size your things are
same Casey where can they work in the
house of the or is it not
Spotify is thatis tiny tea with DJ no
available no someone's gone on and taken
out it's Danny T DJ there's actually in
Australian
we didn't talk about him I can't do in
Australia I was gonna do it stunning
teen an Australian accent back huh
anyway yeah actually no we're friends
now can see what can I get you online or
you just get you please on these hides
away you know this is the case your
voice also I am yeah I only have
Instagram and it what is it I don't even
know like I see so that media as a
business talks I'm not big proactive on
it I'm gonna send everyone there anyway
it's gonna be in the show notes real
when was you when was your last picture
it's gotta be four years thousands 1750
yeah yeah well you've got someone else's
social media deal with them yeah ladies
and gentlemen everything will be linked
in the show notes below any questions
you've got for Danny feel free to leave
them on YouTube like share and subscribe
you know what to do Danny it's been
fantastic when I'm looking for stir
tonight's gonna be buzzy I'm gonna get
you drunk no bigger people than you have
tried a cure
yeah you didn't give it a crack Thanks
[Music]
you